I'd go in a room with Putin you would go
I would yeah a thousand percent
I get it that's right Adam
that's right
well first you would give him a that's
right probably ah getting a given us to
see see that and here's the issue that
trips everybody up in negotiations the
difference between hearing and speaking
the same words are vastly different and
what I'm looking for is what I'm the
responses I'm getting out of you
because if you if you can't first that's
right especially like if you can't
appreciate what that really means
hearing it is unsatisfying so those two
words are really important to you talk
about this in your book what is why is
that so what does that's right mean why
is it important well it means that what
you just heard you think is
unequivocably the truth
like it's dead on it hit the target it's
it's a bullseye
and it's been a topic of discussion
especially between my son and I a lot
like what happens
the oxytocin bonding moment
and he his contention has always been
like Donald Trump is the poster child of
what it means because
Donald Trump's been addressing an
audience you know he's he's in a debate
with Hillary or he's given a speech
someplace
and when the people that are devoted to
him
when they believe that he what he's just
said is completely right it's insightful
they look at him or they look at the TV
and they go that's right
and it's a it's what people say when
they're bought into what they just heard
now if you're not convinced of the way
that Donald Trump's followers are bonded
to him
and he he also just like this in my view
destroys the idea of common ground
because when he first started to run for
president the pundits
all said as a New Yorker
nobody in the Republican party is going
to like him it's Middle America you know
it's blue collar you know it's regular
common folks
Factory workers
they're not gonna like Trump because
he's from New York and he went to Warden
he's an Ivy Leaguer and he's a son of a
wealthy Real Estate Mogul and he had a
million dollars handed to him when he
got out of college
he you know he's born with a silver
Spruce spoon in his mouth the rank and
fire Republicans and never gonna accept
this guy
based on common ground
look how look how smart that was do you
think he's a good negotiator do you
think Donald Trump is a good negotiator
uh no
I think he's a great marketer
if you look at his negotiation track
record all right so I started following
Donald Trump in the 80s when I was in
New York I'm a last century guy he's the
last century guy we've got mutual
acquaintances
the minister that married him to milor
Maples was a friend of mine in a close
friend of mine and in 1998 I threw a
fundraiser in his apartment a Trump
Tower that he attended
so
um no shortage of mutual friends we went
to the same church
still have mutual mutual acquaintances
friends
I don't know and watched his track
record negotiation history
which is exactly his track record with
North Korea where are we with North
Korea what was the deal that he made
with North Korea
see your answer is the same as everybody
else's
well I remember it started out with a
lot of fanfare yeah but I don't know
what happened because nothing ever
happens as more public Fanfare so
marketing minded presentation with a
bang if he doesn't cut the deal in a
short period a really short period of
time he moves on
and everybody wonders what happened
because there was so much fanfare at the
beginning now
at the beginning him even opening that
dialogue with North Korea was masterful
like I was I was such a fan when you got
a president of the United States
that is willing to sit down and talk
with the leader of another Nation when
every other president all our advisors
are saying the leader of North Korea is
beneath you you cannot dignify him by
responding to him directly and
consequently
the Trump Administration inherits a can
of worms
that has been simmering for 30 years
he didn't get us into that and he and he
opened up a dialogue where nobody else
was capable of opening a dialogue and it
just went away
nobody knows what happened
and there was no deal made
now great negotiators make deals
what do you think about these
accusations that he's a narcissist
if you're a narcissist does that help
you or hurt you
is there a more popular term these days
than narcissist like everybody's a
narcissist everybody you don't like is a
narcissist like the homeless guy done on
the corner he's a narcissist that's why
he's there yeah it's lost meaning for
you a little bit Yeah and first of all
most psychological terms
is a hostage negotiator and really uh we
were never into psychology
and we steered away from it because
psychology is at best is a soft science
if it's not informed these days if it's
not informed by
real studies or
um
Neuroscience the guys that I'm impressed
with these days psychologists
neuroscientists now I wanna I'm I'm
interested in that that that guy or gal
but then psychology convention do you
get them all together and they all agree
yeah but also the interesting thing
about psychology is each individual
person
is way more complicated than the
category psychology tries to create and
there's something about the human brain
the moment you classify somebody's a
narcissist or depressed or bipolar
or insane in any kind of way for some
reason you don't use you give yourself a
convenient excuse not to see them as a
complicated human being to empathize
with them I had that when I was talking
to I did an interview with Kanye West
and then there's a lot of popular
opinions about
um him being mentally unwell and so on
right and I felt that that kind of way
of thinking is a very convenient way of
thinking to ignore the fact that he's a
human being
that again wants to be understood and
heard
and that's the only way you can have
that conversation
yeah I agree completely that's right
I feel so close to you now